now I I totally understand the court
system okay I I totally do so I know
it's not that simple I do but at some
point you guys are creating monsters
because you give these chicks whatever
they want and 90% of them don't deserve
it I mean really like what are chicks
doing I was asking around guys I know
how much they spend on their women and
they said I think they said like two
grand a month that was like the
consensus or I think it was like a 10K a
year for a girlfriend and I really
thought to myself I'm like what on Earth
is this girl doing to get $10,000 a year
that's like a part-time job I thought to
myself like what but this is the problem
even on first dates I thought about this
I really think women should spend money
on men I don't even really like
traditionalism because traditionalism
just puts women on a pedestal I mean the
man must take you on a date he has to
plan it he has to do everything when
women really are not happy unless
they're doing for you that is the only
way I have seen relationships work when
the woman is doing for the man